[Music]
chrissy teigen introduces her newborn
son to the world
Linna well I'm here meet miles Theodore
Stephens Crissy and hubby John Legend's
second child we would have more I don't
know the timing but we definitely would
have at least a couple they're already
proud parents two two-year-old luna the
32 year old model shared the adorable
photo of miles on instagram sunday
morning with the caption hello world we
are drowning in his little peeps and
nuzzles our household feels overwhelmed
with love
Chrissy gave birth to the little guy on
Wednesday and has since been sharing
details about his birth both cute and
cringe-worthy on Saturday she made this
hilarious comparison tweeting I can
confirm postpartum life is 90% better
when you don't rip to your butt baby boy
one point Luna zero and the day before
Chrissy revealed one feature that Luna
and miles have in common
quote same nose he is a few weeks early
so he's little and makes the tiniest
noises in April Teigen told et her
daughter couldn't wait to become a big
sister she is so excited she actually
she's got her little baby doll now that
she's been really taken care of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]